somebody you know well you've worked
together closely on some of the ideas
behind open ai's Elon Musk you have
agreed on a lot of things you've
disagreed on some things what have been
some interesting things you've agreed
and disagreed on speaking of a fun
debate on Twitter
I think we agree on the magnitude of the
downside of AGI and the need to get
not only safety rights
but get to a world where people are much
better off
because AGI exists and if AGI had never
been built
yeah
what do you disagree on
Elon is obviously attacking us some on
Twitter right now on a few different
vectors and I have empathy because I
believe he is
understandably so really stressed about
AGI safety
I'm sure there are some other
motivations going on too but that's
definitely one of them
um
I saw this video of Elon
a long time ago talking about SpaceX
maybe it's on some new show and a lot of
early Pioneers in space were really
bashing
SpaceX and maybe Elon too
and
he was visibly very hurt by that and
said
you know those guys are heroes of mine
and I sucks and I wish they would see
how hard we're trying
um I definitely grew up with Elon as a
hero of mine
um
You know despite him being a jerk on
Twitter whatever I'm happy he exists in
the world
but
I wish he would
do more to look at the hard work we're
doing to get this stuff right
a little bit more love
what do you admire in the Name of Love a
body almost
I mean so much right like he has
he has driven the world forward in
important ways I think we will get to
electric vehicles much faster than we
would have if he didn't exist I think
we'll get to space much faster than we
would have if he didn't exist
and
as a sort of like
a citizen of the world I'm very
appreciative of that also like being a
jerk on Twitter aside in many instances
he's like a very funny and warm guy
and uh some of the jerk on Twitter thing
uh as a fan of humanity laid out in its
full complexity and Beauty I enjoy the
tension of ideas expressed so uh you
know I earlier said to admire how
transparent you are but I like how the
battles are happening before our eyes as
opposed to everybody closing off inside
boardrooms it's all yeah you know maybe
I should hit back and maybe someday I
will but it's not like my normal Style
it's all fascinating to watch and I
think both of you are brilliant people
and have early on for a long time really
cared about AGI and had had great
concerns about a job but a great hope
for AGI and that's cool to see
um these big Minds having those
discussions uh even if they're tense at
times
I think it was Elon that said that uh
gbt is too woke
uh is GPT to walk
as can you still man the case that it is
and not this is going to ours
um question about bias honestly I barely
know what woke means anymore I did for a
while and I feel like the word is
morphed so I will say I think it was too
biased and
will always be there will be no one
version of GPT that the world ever
agrees is unbiased
what
I think is we've made a lot like again
even some of our harshest critics have
gone off and been tweeting about 3.5 to
4 comparisons and being like wow these
people really got a lot better not that
they don't have more work to do and we
certainly do but I I appreciate critics
who display intellectual honesty like
that yeah and there there's been more of
that than I would have thought
um we will try to get the default
version to be as
neutral as possible but as neutral as
possible is not that neutral if you have
to do it again for more than one person
and so this is where more steerability
more control in the hands of the user
the system message in particular
is I think the real path forward
and as you pointed out these nuanced
answers that look at something from
several angles yeah it's really really
fascinating it's really fascinating is
there something to be said about the
employees of a company affecting the
bias of the system 100 uh we try to
avoid the SF
group think bubble it's harder to avoid
the AI group think bubble that follows
you everywhere there's all kinds of
bubbles we live in 100 yeah I'm going on
like uh around the world user tour soon
for a month to just go like talk to our
users in different cities
and I can like feel how much I'm craving
doing that because I haven't done
anything like that since in years
um I used to do that more for YC and to
go talk to people in super different
contexts
and it doesn't work over the Internet
like to go show up in person and like
sit down and like
go to the bars they go to and kind of
like walk through the city like they do
you learn so much
and get out of the bubble so much
um
I think we are much better than any
other company I know of in San Francisco
for not falling into the kind of like
SF craziness but I I'm sure we're still
pretty deeply in it but is it possible
to separate the bias of the model versus
the bias of the employees
the bias I'm most nervous about is the
bias of the human feedback Raiders uh so
what's the selection of the human is
there something you could speak to at a
high level about the selection of the
human Raiders this is the part that we
understand the least well we're great at
the pre-training Machinery
um we're now trying to figure out how
we're going to select those people how
like how we'll like verify that we get a
representative sample how we'll do
different ones for different places but
we don't we don't know that
functionality built out yet
such a fascinating
um
science you clearly don't want like all
American Elite University students
giving you your labels well see it's not
about I just can never resist that dig
yes nice
but it's so that that's a good
there's a million heuristics you can use
that's a to me that's a shallow
heuristic because uh Universe like any
one kind of category of human that you
would think would have certain beliefs
might actually be really open-minded in
an interesting way so you have to like
optimize for how good you are actually
answering doing these kinds of rating
tasks how good you are empathizing with
an experience of other humans that's a
big one like and being able to actually
like what does the world view look like
for all kinds of groups of people that
would answer this differently I mean I
have to do that uh constantly instead of
like you've asked this a few times but
it's something I often do you know I ask
people
in an interview or whatever to Steel Man
uh the beliefs of someone they really
disagree with and the inability of a lot
of people to even pretend like they're
willing to do that is remarkable
yeah what I find unfortunately ever
since covid even more so that there's
almost an emotional barrier it's not
even an intellectual barrier before they
even get to the intellectual there's an
emotional barrier that says no anyone
who might possibly believe
X
they're they're an idiot they're evil
they're malevolent anything you want to
assign it's like they're not even like
loading in the data into their head look
I think we'll find out that we can make
GPT systems way less biased than any
human yeah
so hopefully without the
because there won't be that emotional
load there yeah the emotional load
uh but there might be pressure there
might be political pressure oh there
might be pressure to make a bias system
what I meant is the technology I think
will be capable of being
much less biased